we begin in New York city where the
mayor and City officials are grappling
with a growing migrant crisis another
bus carrying illegal immigrants from the
border arrived in the Big Apple earlier
today
and state and city officials they are
now desperately searching for places to
house the thousands more expected to be
on the way earlier this week New York
City began housing migrants in several
Public School gymnasiums across the five
boroughs mayor Eric Adams positioned the
plan as just a temporary solution while
the city identified more potential
housing options but it didn't take long
for those migrants to begin lining the
streets of these school zones with these
migrants Gathering outside their shelter
at an elementary school near Coney
Island now City officials they are
reversing course and moving migrants out
of the schools but it only came after
parents and students took to the streets
[Music]
[Applause]
we wanted foreign
you know Congressman this is just common
sense you've got 11 and 12 year old
girls and you are going to put single
adult males beside them not just single
adult males but single adult males who
haven't been vetted we know people on
the terror watch list have crossed the
border MS-13 members potentially and you
put them beside our crown jewels our
little babies that's right common sense
and this is on the local government a
lot of this debate has been where's the
Biden Administration here's these are
all the different ways you could better
secure a border generally it's bad that
New York City has these Sanctuary City
policies but what gets worse is when at
the local level you don't have the
answers to who are these people where's
their documentation are they vaccinated
do they bring any health concerns are
they a a threat to our kids for uh some
type of a you know sexual abuse
background that maybe you don't know
that the list goes on it's on the local
governments that these people are on
vetted in that situation this is beyond
just blaming the vitamin Administration
it's beyond that you know it's blaming
New York governance from Top all the way
down you know Harris and it's low-income
children I want to be very clear who's
being affected here it's low-income
children in many of these situations
thankfully reversing course but it's the
same Trend we saw with the pandemic
right let's close the schools and we
know who was hurt most it was the most
vulnerable children in our country hurt
most they are always last I want people
to understand the makeup of P.S 172 in
particular and and you really could say
this about pretty much any inner city
school here in the New York five
boroughs when
um the city government said that oh you
know they're in the adjacent gym they
were like 20 feet apart right because
there's no real State left in New York
so these children very young children
were housed potentially going to be
long-term because everybody keeps saying
oh no no from the city's office the
mayor's office it was going to be
short-term well it wasn't supposed to be
13 hours right the parents won on this
so just a few minutes before this show
began uh Miguel Chico he has two
daughters at PS 72 and he said he was
part of that you know we stood out we
organized in front of the school you saw
some of that video and they said to the
school look we have a heart for the the
immigrants they need water and they need
showers they can't get that here in the
gym but our girls need to be protected
too they don't need to be with adults so
the parents won it's interesting of
course we win our voices matter but more
importantly he kept his kids home
so the school has no way to do anything
but become a shelter if the kids aren't
in the school
which was effective but again the kids
pay just as you said during the pandemic
yeah they always are the ones who pay
and we may all pay soon Emily uh this
caught my attention listen to what
governor hokel says we might expect to
see all across New York
let us have a large field and operations
we can put up the tents you're going to
start seeing people living in tents not
just on the border but in the streets of
New York and across New York State
because we've reached a Breaking Point
tents all across the state sounds like
Portland exactly I was going to say it
sounds like the West Coast
um and Congressman I actually would love
your further Insight in this because as
a gubernatorial candidate you know we
talk about the tension between his use
of the local government and then down
from Albany here we know that because of
a restraining order that was levied by a
judge temporarily the plan to bust these
migrants from New York City to Suburban
counties was quashed but temporarily we
are now dealing with just under 45 000
migrants in this city with 13 to 15
buses expected in the next couple days
so can you illuminate a little bit more
the tension between Albany and New York
City and also what Suburban residents
can do who are living in these counties
at the behest of this Governor at the
behest of this mayor who is spreading
this toxicity to the other counties
what's worse than asking the question
who's going to pay for it and when will
this end is when you have people who
know that they're the ones who are going
to have to pay for it and they know that
this will never end this will keep
getting worse every day
there are Democrats who are now saying
that there's an emergency they're using
words like this is a crisis they're
right but they're only asking for money
they have their hands out they think
that more money is going to fix it I
want to see somebody like a Kathy hokel
or an Eric Adams these Democrats to call
up President Biden and say finish
construction of the border wall don't
get rid of title 42 unless you have a
replacement and force the remain in
Mexico policy supporter of Customs and
Border Patrol agents and catch and
release they're not talking about policy
solutions that will actually fix it
they're just saying give us more money
as if that's going to make this go away
from that point let me just pull up this
sound bite we only have it in a full
screen so we couldn't get the sound but
take a listen to this from Governor
hokel to the point of money republicans
in Congress in charge of the house have
the ability to allocate more money why
don't you match what New York state did
give us a billion dollars for New York
help us with the money help us with the
work authorization and then we'll get
through much sooner money's not your
answer governor people changes in
Congress which by the way Republicans
passed last week and the Senate didn't
take up and Joe Biden said he would veto
on a national level sure but what what
I've talked to some some sources here in
the city that tell me that there's a
bigger plan here happening under Eric
Adams and what he wants to do and Hogle
just said it as well and that sound bite
is you're going to start seeing tents on
the streets tents in Central Park these
are real conversations because they want
to make sure that the outrage that the
parents are angry the taxpayers are
angry everybody is it's all over every
newscast national and local to where the
bite Administration will respond with
money but there's another side to this
the other thing that Adams wants to do
and that this is behind the scenes and
this is what they think is happening now
is that he wants to push to where
there's actual legal change on the state
level in Albany Lee and you know this
because they have to actually change the
sanctuary city laws at what point does
this issue get so large and so
combustible that New York City has and
the state and this has to be a they have
to work together is no longer a
sanctuary city right to shelter which
has also created the homeless disaster
and the homeless industrial complex that
is a billion dollar multi-billion dollar
industry in this city all the taxpayers
are paying for that right to shelter
though pushes out American citizens like
those veterans that we saw up in Upstate
New York I mean that's what that legally
would be allowed to do but just wrap
your mind around a billion dollars for
about between 61 and 65 000 uh illegal
immigrants that have come in since last
spring that I did the math if it's 65
000 16
343 dollars per person I mean that's a
salary yeah because I don't think they
pay taxes on it right we can't the city
can't afford it I just want to throw
that out there I'll I'll leave it
has allocated a billion dollars for 65
000 people give or take and then she
wants a matching from the federal
government where is all that money going
to go what why does she need all of that
what is that for corrupt service
providers I'll stop corrupt service
providers and the victim of Biden's
border crisis not just the kids in the
schools here in New York the children
crossing the border an eight-year-old
died in Border Patrol custody a 17 year
old last week children are dying and our
president is doing nothing hey everyone
I'm Emily compagno catch me and my
co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcaneny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights